bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver émission
spéciale ce soir emmanuel macron
s'adresse aux français pour la première
fois depuis le séisme électoral de
dimanche le président de la république
va tirer les enseignements du scrutin
quelles solutions pour sortir de
l'impasse parlementaire analyses et
réactions de nos invités sur ce plateau
dans un instant un séisme électoral qui
se traduit aussi par l'entrée en force
du rassemblement national à l'assemblée
c'est l'image du jour marine le pen n'a
pas boudé son plaisir ce matin opposants
avec ses 88 collègues sur les marches du
palais bourbon l'assemblée ultime étape
de la normalisation du r n nous en
parlerons également fin la bataille pour
le perchoir est lancé qui a le plus de
chances de succéder à richard ferrand à
la présidence de l'assemblée l amende un
gars va nous dira pourquoi cette journée
était si crucial voilà pour le menu de
cette émission spéciale tu fais partie
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs pour une fois le
président n'aura pas tardé à prendre la
parole trois jours après le choc
électorale des législatives
emmanuel macron va donc s'adresser
solennellement aux français dans une
demi heure maintenant depuis l'elysée et
vous pourrez suivre son allocution en
direct bonsoir edwige yade merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes l'un
des nouveaux visages de cette conquête
du rassemblement national au
palais-bourbon élu député de la gironde
territoire où jusqu'ici le parti était
quasiment absent nous en parlerons ce
soir vous allez débattre avec un député
de la majorité la république en marche
marque ferracci lui aussi un nouveau
visage de l'assemblée nationale il est
retenu parce qu'on est en train de faire
une sorte de primaire interne au sein de
la république en marché de la coalition
présidentielle ensemble pour savoir quel
sera le candidat pour le perchoir et
nous rejoint dans un tout petit instant
bonsoir jean philippe derosier et merci
d'être là vous êtes constitutionnaliste
et professeur de droit public à
l'université de lille enfin bonsoir
erwan lecoeur ravi de vous retrouver sur
ce plateau politologue et sociologue
spécialiste notamment de l'extrême
droite bonsoir évidemment c'était fade
bonsoir myriam soir à tous avant avant
l'allocution présidentielle qu'on va
tous écouter ensemble retour en images
sur cette nouvelle folle journée et oui
elles s'enchaînent à l'assemblée avec
vous stéphane blakowski tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir c'était
jour de gloire pour le rl j'ai bien
compris la star du jour en tout cas à
l'assemblée s'était marine le pen ce
matin avant d'entrer dans l'enceinte
elle avait donné rendez vous aux médias
sur la place ba du palais-bourbon devant
le palais bourbon avec ses 88 députés et
vous allez voir les images enfin vous
allez pas avoir grand chose
si vous voyez une mèche blonde mieux
c'est marine le pen mais c'est ça être
une star c'est quand on ne vous voit
plus derrière les caméras forêt de
caméras heureusement c'était un peu plus
calme une fois les députés est reine à
l'intérieur du palais beau bourg
heureusement qu'on a pas laissé entrer
cette meute de journalistes d'autant
qu'à l'intérieur de la cape de lin de
bain de l'assemblée il y à lcp votre
chaîne préférée qui a pu tout filmé
notamment l'accueil de marine le pen
réservé aux débutants il a fait un
accueil personnalisé tout le monde a son
accolade il ya des petites complètement
novice comme daniel grenon ce monsieur
était cheveux gris qui est un épicier a
dit c'est un peu présenté pour rendre
service mais il ya une telle vague front
national que le voilà élu il a
d'ailleurs battu guillaume larrivé voyez
assez symbolique l air
alors j'imagine qu'ils étaient émus ces
nouveaux députés est reine ouais je vois
vous voulez la séquence émotion le grand
frisson quand on rentre dans l'hémicycle
alors juste avant je vous montre quelque
chose c'est marine le pen qui fait la
visite guidée vous allez voir les
regarder moi j'étais là au tout petit
avec les non inscrits puis je peux on ne
sait jamais parlé maintenant on occupe
toute la place on a vraiment un grand
groupe il appelle le langage corporel
quand on veut faire passer un autre
message ma séquence émotion elle existe
ou pas ah oui non mais je sens que vous
y tenez il ya du pittoresque dans le
groupe à ce que les profils on voit pas
souvent à l'assemblée notamment des
protections annonce qu'un docteur
professionnel qui a été champion du
monde dans cette catégorie un accordeur
de piano qui est aveugle un marin je
sais pas si vous savez il ya même deux
femmes
2 ancienne femme de ménage donc une de
plus qu'elle annule baisse et forcément
on se dit que pour des citoyen presque
ordinaire ça doit être très émouvant de
mettre tes pieds une assemblée dont on a
posé la question ça fait quoi de mettre
pour la première fois les pieds dans
l'hémicycle réponse
attaché parlementaire en 2002 à
l'assemblée nationale donc en fait je
suis déjà rentrée dans cet hémicycle par
contre entre et comme parlementaire
effectivement dans cet hémicycle c'est
un grand moment d'émotion ça fait de
nombreux mois qu'on travaille sur le
terrain pour avoir ce beau résultat de
89 parlementaire et l'émotion était très
forte chez beaucoup d'entre nous ce
matin je sens que vous êtes un peu déçu
parce que ce n'était pas sa première
fois dans l'hémicycle mais voilà on
pense qu'on n'y a que des novices dans
ce groupe or c'est pas tout à fait le
cas juste un chiffre sur les 89 élus et
même 70 on va presque soixante dix qui
ont déjà exercé un mandat local dont il
ya déjà une forte implantation qui était
trahi la ferme était importante pour le
front national bon que certaines
alliances politiques certainement plus
que le groupe a les oreilles quand ils
sont arrivés en 2017 qui était plus
aussi donc si je comprends bien personne
n'a versé une petite larme alors je vous
oublie pas mais vous savez voulait
absolument cette séquence émotion qu est
ce qui se passe et des gens qui sont
émus ils disent je suis ému je trouve
pas les mots bah justement il trouve pas
les mots dans quel intérêt donc là il ya
des professionnels de la communication
o'shea sont pas complètement désarmé la
rn notamment philippe ballard qui est un
ancien journaliste elle fit donc
l'émotion il s'est trouvé l'anecdote
pour bien la raconter on écoute
évidemment c'est beaucoup d'émotion avec
des nouveaux députés qui étaient dans
l'équipe de campagne de marine pour la
présidentielle on se remémorait les
et mois de février où on se disait mais
on va pas arriver aux 500 parrainages
enfin marine va pas pouvoir être
candidate voilà ça c'était il ya juste
quelques mois et maintenant 89 députés
rassemblement national à l'assemblée
voilà c'est magique séquence émotion
garder être vigilent gaz est les larmes
aux yeux en pensant moi c'est vrai ça
veut dire qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup parlé
marine le pen
elle n'a fait qu'une seule chose à la
souris mais alors toute la matinée à
tout le monde il était vraiment contente
le seul moment là complètement arrêté de
sourire c'est quand les journalistes ont
demandé mais alors quelle est votre
stratégie pour votre groupe l'assemblée
l'a finie la rigolade tout ce qui va
dans le sens de l'intérêt de la france
et des français nous le voterons tout ce
qui nous apparaît perfectible nous la
mènerons est tout ce qui nous apparaît
toxiques ou néfaste eh bien nous y
opposerons bon ben voila l à 89 députés
et cinq ans à l'assemblée je vous
rappelle que l'objectif fixé par
bardella c'est prouvé qu'on vaut mieux
de notre caricature qu'on est prêt à
accéder au pouvoir en 2027 merci encore
fait merci pour votre billet merci pour
votre votre regard et de vices diaz je
vais commencer par vous quel opposante
voulez-vous être à l'assemblée nationale
une opposition
respectueuse des institutions et une
opposition responsable
plusieurs fois dans la journée on m'a
dit oui mais ce que vous allez vous
opposer systématiquement alors non c'est
pas notre genre et comme l'a rappelé
monsieur tout à l'heure la plupart
d'entre nous mais on a l'habitude de
siéger dans des hémicycles moi par
exemple je suis présidente du groupe au
conseil régional de nouvelles aquitaine
et donc c'est un exécutif socialiste
quand l'exécutif socialiste propose une
délibération qui va dans le bon sens
bien sûr nous l'avons ton et quand nous
retrouvons des dispositions qui émane de
notre programme bien sûr nous les
votants là je vous donne un exemple j'ai
entendu un ministre indiqué qu'ils
allaient réindexés les pensions de
retraite sur l'inflation retrait pau va
évidemment pas que c'était dans notre
programme donc on va pas voter contre
nous-mêmes juste parce que sur le
pouvoir d'achat grand texte très attendu
une fois que voilà on sera sorti de ses
voilà ce brouillard institutionnels vous
pourriez voter l'ensemble du texte alors
pouvoir d'achat il ya des choses le shaq
alimentaire
attendre de leur grille tarifaire sur le
gaz énergie se voir le texte on va le
lire on va l'amendé on va l'améliorer et
on verra au final qui finalement fait de
l'obstruction ou fait de l'opposition
parce que c'est vrai que moi je vous le
dire au conseil régional de nouvelles
aquitaine à chaque fois que le
rassemblement national propose quelque
chose une motion à l'amendement par
exemple et bien l'exécutif socialiste
par sectarisme le rejette donc là je
pense que c'est un nouvel exercice pour
monsieur macron qui est pour la première
fois obligé de consulter l'opposition
et c'est pas dans ses habitudes parce
que l'ancien quinquennat il ne le
faisait jamais ensemble vous avez
beaucoup réfléchit déjà à la manière
dont vous voulez vous emparer dans ce
fait levier de pouvoir à l'assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas une
novice puisque vous l'avez dit vous
étiez conseil régional de giron qu'est
ce qu'on n'a pas vu donc dans cette dans
cette campagne à bas bruit à votre avis
du rassemblement national vous qui êtes
un peu l'emblème de cette stratégie du
désenclavement la gironde le blayais une
partie du sud ouest n'est pas une terre
du rassemblement national alors c'est
vrai que j'ai été assez surprise que la
nouvelle aquitaine en l'occurrence et la
gironde soit à ce point passer
au travers des radars des observateurs
politiques parce que nous nous
travaillons méticuleusement depuis des
années moi je suis en rassemblant
nationale depuis quasiment dix ans et
marine quand elle a pris les rênes du rn
elle avait dit il faut tout miser sur
l'implantation locale le maillage
territorial prouver que nous sommes des
candidats sérieux quand nous nous
présentons aux élections est prouvé que
nous sommes des élus sérieux quand nous
siégeons donc c'est ce que nous avons
fait et en fait nous avons construit cet
enracinement pour vous donner un exemple
très concret en 2020 ou dans des
élections municipales en gironde nous
avions présenté 25 liste s'était déjà
historique l'année dernière au moment
des élections régionales le fn est
devenu en nouvelles aquitaine la
première force d'opposition ça aussi
c'était historique et donc voilà nous
avons construit cet enracinement si bien
qu'aujourd'hui en gironde nous avons
obtenu deux députés et en nouvelles
aquitaine six députés erwan lecoeur tout
le monde a été surpris 89 députés c'est
un score historique pour ce parti sans
la proportionnelle on l'a dit on l'a
redit plus de deux millions de voix par
rapport aux précédentes législatives
et par rapport au premier tour donc
c'est vraiment un fait politique de ces
législatives en entendant et de vision
sans que voilà il ya déjà un discours
qui est rodé une opposition sérieuse
constructif je crois même que marine le
pen a exigé la cravate pour vos
collègues masculins l'idée c'est
d'apparaître quoi comme les l'antithèse
des insoumis
d'abord c'est de faire oublier ce qu'a
été le rassemblement national avant
c'est à dire le front national quand il
a été à l'assemblée nationale en 86
c'est l inverse c'était pour y mettre le
bazar pour voter à la place des gens qui
n'étaient pas là pour éructer dans les
travées c'était un peu à la sauce le pen
père tel qu'il avait été lui dans les
années 50 puisque je rappelle qu'il
avait été le plus jeune député en 56
poujadiste donc première chose le
rassemblement national veut faire
oublier ses qualités le front national
ça c'est une évidence et on voit bien
dans le discours c'est l'ultime étape de
la normalisation évidemment répéter le
problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas quelle
est l'ultime avant qu'elle arrive c'est
une étape supplémentaire bien entendu
dans la normalisation c'est d'ailleurs
en grande partie ce qui explique les
scores qui ont été obtenus dans un
certain nombre d'endroits où il y avait
potentiellement une victoire au bout là
où il n'y avait pas de victoire les gens
ne se sont pas déplacés comme aux
municipales aux municipales et
régionales je rappelle que ça a été un
échec pour le rassemblement national
parce que ils ont regagné les villes où
ils étaient à peu près présent et puis
ils ont gagné une langue en plus et puis
là où il ne s'est pas présent ils ont
perdu la moitié de leurs élus donc la
plantation locale elle n'était pas du
tout là c'est même un des problèmes du
rassemblement national depuis des années
c'est qu'il n'y a plus de management
intermédiaire que le parti s'est vidée
des élus des années 90 et 2000 et qu'il
a fallu renouveler je dirais le les
eskers sera possible c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de cadres parmi les investis et
lui
voit quand même la députée qu'il ya des
profils de novices mais cela presque ont
été battus on les a vus 1 sur des
plateaux dans l'est dans les débats sur
les chaînes régionales là il ya une
volonté de faire de ce groupe une rampe
de lancement c'est ça pour 2000 pour
2027 on a l'impression que le groupe
parlementaire m va être plus important
que le parti c'est ce qui manquait au
rassemblement national d'abord de gagner
des législatives parce que le mode de
scrutin ne le permettait pas comme pour
les écologistes et un l'autre bout c'est
un autre sujet l'étude les écologistes
non plus n'ont jamais pu avoir de groupe
autonome à l'assemblée parce que les
petits partis n'y arrivait pas l'autre
chose c'est que comme il n'y a pas
beaucoup de formations internes comme il
faut recruter des gens régulièrement
rassemblement national oui l'assemblée
était un point de passage nécessaire
pour gouvernementale is et
potentiellement à terme le rassemblement
national qui pour l'instant gagné les
européennes et beaucoup de voix aux à la
présidentielle mais pas dans les
élections intermédiaires là où elle
était peu présent et pas surtout dans
les législatives donc cette fois c'est
fait en effet il ya une phase de plus
dans la normalisation qui a été aidé par
deux phénomènes qu'il ne faut pas mettre
de côté qui sont des phénomènes
conjoncturels absolument nécessaire
parce que de mon instinct de la vie et
tous les chercheurs voulions le
rassemblement national et la plupart des
observateurs ne s'attendait pas à autant
d'élus on s'attendait à 30 à 60 au
maximum et ils ont été beaucoup aidé par
l'anti macro nisme qui s'est renouvelée
pendant l'entre-deux-tours est aussi
sorti macron à la place devront régler
15 30 et surtout surtout par quelque
chose qui est tout à fait inédit pour la
première fois le front républicain non
seulement est mort
réellement mais en plus on est allé plus
loin puisqu'un certain nombre
d'électeurs et de l'anip s et deux
ensembles ont voté pour le rassemblement
national
la mer est maintenant bien margés aux us
pour cent des électeurs delhaize
allemagne qu'on voit plus on rend leur
champion ou leur candidat n était pas
dans les duels ont voté
nationale rassemblement la faire perdre
l'adversaire principal qui était
ensemble pour le nuc baisse et la nuit
baisse pour ensemble et là c'est quand
même un peu une première de le dire de
le faire et de le voir dans l'électorat
soutient philippe derosier d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant les premiers sondages
montrent c'est un sondage et lab pour
bfm tv et l'express que les français
considèrent des d'ores et déjà depuis
les législatives que c'est marine le pen
qui incarne le mieux l'opposition à
emmanuel macron 48 % loin devant
jean-luc mélenchon 31% un peu
l'impression que c'est un sans faute
cette campagne du rassemblement national
vous le constitutionnaliste qui
connaissait bien le mode de scrutin qui
avait plaidé pour parfois un peu de
proportionnelle non jamais jamais alors
est-ce que c'est quand même une bonne
chose qu enfin l'assemblée nationale
représente le pays alors oui c'est
toujours une bonne chose que l'assemblée
nationale représente le pays et
l'assemblée nationale a toujours
représenté le pays et je me suis
toujours élevé en faux contre justement
le fait de dire que parce que le front
national représente 30 % au niveau des
suffrages exprimés il aurait droit
attendent % de sièges au sein de
l'assemblée nationale nous avons un
méthode un mode de fonctionnement que
certains peuvent contester et que
d'autres défendent je fais partie plutôt
de ceux là effectivement je suis
absolument pas favorable à la
proportionnelle
même une dose ni doses ni overdose mais
pas de petite dose de démocratie on fait
la démocratie 8,40
absolument jusqu'à présent et c'est un
bharati c'est un parti qui n'est pas
capable de s'unir il n'est jamais allé à
une élection surtout une élection
nationale en faisant une union même à
cette élection si où il y avait pourtant
un allié a priori tout trouvé dans la
même mouvance politique de l'extrême
droite ils n'ont pas réussi à conclure
une union ils n'en ont pas voulu ils ont
obtenu 89 députés effectivement je fais
partie de ceux qui ont été un petit peu
surpris par le par le résultat je le
prendrai même particulièrement
non mais je le confesse j'ai aucune
aucune difficulté à cela effectivement
c'est très bien que il y est
un
reflet de la diversité de notre pays qui
était déjà présent d'ailleurs sous la
législature précédente on a eu je ne
sais combien de groupes parlementaires
au sein de au sein de l'assemblée
nationale mais qu'un parti qui est
incapable de s'unir plaide pour un mode
de scrutin qui impose l'union parce
qu'on ne peut pas gouverner sur la base
de la proportionnelle sans faire d union
moi j'ai toujours trouvé ça paradoxal
mais c'est dit bonsoir marque la rade ci
soient les bienvenus sur ce plateau vous
aussi vous êtes l'un des nouveaux
visages de l'assemblée nationale élue
députée la république en marche ensemble
des français établi en suisse alors il
ya plusieurs questions à vous poser déjà
on imagine on voit rester sur le
rassemblement national pour l'instant
avant d'écouter l'allocution du
président à 20h tous ensemble c'est un
peu votre échec aujourd'hui vous le
dirait celui du président de la
république cette percée
dont je pense pas que ce soit un échec
on est face à une situation qui est
inédite on y passait une situation que
la vème république n'avait jamais
réellement connu une situation dans
laquelle l'assemblée nationale est
fragmenté avec normand une majorité
présidentielle qui est une majorité
présidentielle n'en déplaise à certains
commentateurs qui a aujourd'hui un
nombre de députés qui en allant chercher
d'autres députés de bonne volonté à
gauche ou à droite aura la capacité à
faire voter des textes donc je ne pense
pas que ce soit un échec je pense que il
ya la possibilité aujourd'hui de
porter ce projet auquel nous avons cru à
ce projet sur lequel emmanuel macron a
été élu à plus de 58% et de ce point de
vue les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines les prochains mois nous diront
comment ça se passe mais présidence il a
tiré les enseignements silva reconnaître
sa défaite à ces élections quels seront
ses mots c'est important ce moment est
très important pour les français ce soir
parce que même si c'était trois jours
après le scrutin c'est assez c'est assez
long par rapport aux au séisme électoral
que que l'on a tous vécu on parlait du
front républicain
erwan lecoeur nous et les morts
complètement c'est vrai que parmi les
électeurs ma chronique ou en tout cas
des lecteurs d emmanuel macron il ya eu
des reports sur le rassemblement
national minoritaire mais 12% c'est pas
rien il y aura des duels face à l'as du
ps il y en a eu mais vous a pas échappé
non plus que les reports des électeurs
delà du ps vers le rassemblement
national ont été plus importants donc je
pense qu'il est à peu près similaire peu
près similaire donc tout état de cause
en tout état de cause je pense qu'on a
chacun à faire face par deux nous
députés avec une responsabilité
collective à la montée du rassemblement
national on sait que c'est un parti qui
exprime et qui surf eux mêmes sur un
certain nombre de peurs de colère
d'émotions depuis déjà très longtemps
nous avons toujours eu une démarche
assez différente de faire de la
politique une démarche qui consiste et
bien à essayer de construire un projet
crédible pour le pays pense que ce
mouvement est ce parti politique n'a pas
de projet crédible pour le pays mais y'a
pas quand même à une autocritique quand
emmanuel macron en 2017 a été élu il a
été élu avec l'objectif on se souvient
de ces mots de bâton réduire au maximum
le rassemblement national et de faire en
sorte que ces électeurs choisissent une
autre option c'était vous souvenez le
duel des progressistes contre les
nationalistes aujourd'hui 89 députés
c'est vraiment historique vous n'y voyez
aucune forme de responsabilité des
responsabilités
je pense qu'on les établira avec un
petit peu plus de recul il ya une
déception je peux pas vous mentir il ya
évidemment une déception je suis je suis
quelqu'un qui s'est engagé en politique
pour lutter contre lise et l'extrême
droite je suis quelqu'un qui s'est
engagé en politique a pour effectivement
arriver à faire en sorte que des partis
comme le front national et je parle du
front national parce que je pense qu'il
ya une similarité qui n'aura échappé à
personne entre les deux est bien et le
moins d'audience politique personnelle
pour vous situer parce que vous êtes un
nouveau député mais vous connaissez
quand même bien les rouages du pouvoir
puisque vous avez passé cinq ans dans
les ministères récemment à matignon puis
au ministère du travail des affaires
sociales vous êtes économiste
spécialiste des questions liées au
travail et vous avez peser notamment sur
plusieurs réformes les ordonnances
travail sur l'assurance chômage sur
l'apprentissage et de vices diaz bon là
voilà les camps sont très claires vous
vous nous avez dit vous montrer quelques
mesures peut-être matière de pouvoir
d'achat opposition sérieuse et
constructive voilà ce qu'on entend ce
soir dans la majorité ça c'est exclu
parce qu'on la cherche cette majorité
elle était introuvable
alors nous on servira jamais de
marchepied emmanuel macron ça c'était
leur taux skier tentative de trouver des
majorités d'idées qu'on est là sur ces
hypothèses texte après texte on voit que
c'est sarko mais je crois qu'on est
dedans on peut pas participer la
majorité des manuels macron que l'on
combat de toutes nos forces et avec 1
avec un succès relatif même si c'est pas
forcément agréable pour vous de
l'entendre mais mais c'est clair que
nous on a fait on a pris un engagement
vis-à-vis de nos électeurs on leur a dit
écoutez emmanuel macron vous a fait du
mal nous on va essayer de réparer ce mal
ça et moi sur ma circonscription
j'ai rencontré des gens qui sont dans
une misère dans une pop hérité très très
indigne j'ai rencontré des gens sur le
marché qui me disait écoute edwige mois
avant je m'achetais un poulet entier
aujourd'hui je m'achète qu'un demi
poulet parce que je n'ai pas
suffisamment pour finir mon moi et ça
c'est la politique des matchs du manuel
macro qui en est responsable parce qu'il
n'a pas voulu pendant quatre ans ray
indexées les pensions de retraite sur
l'inflation parce qu'il a revêtu
opposition vous faites on dirait
vraiment les classes populaires dans
l'hémicycle véritablement avec les
différents profils plus que ça mais en
tout cas qu'une le rappeur français qui
restera sur le sur le trottoir voilà
face à emmanuel macron cas été très
méprisant à l'égard des français
notamment à l'égard des français des
zones rurales qui ont subi la fracture
territoriale la désertification des
services publics la perte du pouvoir
d'achat eh bien nous on dit écoutez là
on a cinq ans pour travailler de manière
très sérieuse alors n'avoir rien entendu
ni à part ont évidemment 2011 edouard
philippe qui prônent une coalition qui a
été entendu par le président à l'elysée
aujourd'hui très clairement cette idée
de coalition ne va absolument pas
jusqu'à vous le rn ou ce jusqu'à et les
filles on va ouvrir une page spéciale il
ya beaucoup d'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale avec l'examen d'un gars qui
nous attend salle des quatre colonnes à
7 minutes maintenant de l'allocution
présidentielle pardonnez moi aller
devant l'assemblée nationale place du
palais bourbon elle date alors parlez
nous de cette actualité la bataille pour
le perchoir est bel et bien lancée est
ce qu on sait qui peut succéder à
richard ferrand
alors il y à un intergroupe qui a lieu
en ce moment myriam c'est à dire une
réunion de tous les groupes de la
majorité renaissance modem et horizons
ils sont en train de faire un scrutin
interne pour désigner leur candidat
le premier tour a eu lieu et on connaît
donc la fiche pour le deuxième tour il
opposera yaël brume privé qui a obtenu
87 voix et roland lescure qui en obtenu
67 alors y est lebron pie v c'est une
députée des yvelines elle était
présidente de la commission des lois ici
à l'assemblée nationale avant de devenir
ministre d outre mer roland lescure il
était également président de commission
celle des affaires économiques il était
le des français de l'étranger il vivait
à montréal avant de devenir député en
2017 ya une brune qui dès roland lescure
voici donc la fiche pour le deuxième
tour mon annonce des résultats autour de
20h 15 environ elsa ça veut dire que
yaël brune puis vais où roland lescure
ça dépendra de ce vote vous allez nous
dire ce que vous en pensez dans un
instant marque ferracci devrait en toute
logique être élu au perchoir mardi
prochain c'est lui ou elle en toute
logique oui en toute logique myriam nom
va quand même prendre des précautions
parce qu'ici à l'assemblée nationale on
vit une période assez exceptionnel
évidemment normalement le candidat de la
majorité était lui même si la majorité
relative
il pourrait être en difficulté
uniquement s'il ya une alliance des
oppositions qui se mettraient d'accord
pour un autre candidat mais ça ce serait
vraiment extraordinaire parce qu'on voit
mal les députés de la nuque voté dans le
même sens que des députés de droite ou
du rassemblement national met donc on se
donne rendez vous évidemment mardi
prochain dernière question elsa y avait
d'autres groupes politiques importants
qui élisaient leur chef aujourd'hui
wheeler président commence par une
présidente puisque le principal groupe
ici à l'assemblée c'est le groupe
renaissance et il aura à sa tête une
femme les députés ont élu aurore bergé
elle est élue des yvelines elle vient de
la droite et elle va donc occuper un
poste stratégique ici à l'assemblée en
tant que président du groupe majoritaire
elle sait que le défi est grand et coûté
la vie à chaque fois on dit que c'est un
des pires poste dans un hamac facile
mais cette époque qu'on souhaite parce
que ce sont des postes qui sont
exigeants qui sont essentiels et qui
permettent encore une fois d'avoir une
majorité de pouvoir tenir ensemble
autre nomination ce matin les
républicains se sont dotés d'un nouveau
chef à l'assemblée c'est olivier marc
l'ex le député d'eure et loir qui prend
la tête du groupe lui il est sur une
ligne assez anti macro on sait que son
groupe il est convoité par la majorité
pour obtenir la majorité absolue
justement attention il prévient les
républicains ne sont pas à vendre
écouter n'ont évidemment pas de contre à
deux pas d'un contrat de gouvernement et
puis
la période ou pouvaient donner le
sentiment de négocier des postes
pour choix est évidemment totalement
terminée nous sommes un groupe
d'opposition
voilà myriam on a vécu l'arrivée des
députés là c'est la constitution des
groupes et l'élection des présidents y
aura beaucoup de femmes dans les ca
notables un math il pas noël a été réélu
chez les insoumis marine le pen à elle
prendra la présidence de son groupe du
rassemblement national chez les
socialistes en revanche valérie rabault
n'est pas candidate à sa succession ce
sera forcément un homme à la tête du
groupe puisque trois députés sont
candidats boris vallot jérôme guedj ou
guillaume garot résultats demain lors
d'un vote à 10 heures merci pour ce tour
d'horizon des élections internes et de
la bataille pour le père soir est la
marque ferracci olivier marleix hxc la
ligne dure on a entendu au sein des
républicains ça s'annonce mal quand on
sait déjà les les commissions d'enquêté
sur l'affairé alsthom quand on connaît
le personnage il n'y a aucun aucune
chance qu'il ne quitte l'opposition et
il a véritablement pas envie de vous
faire de cadeaux c'est pas décourageant
d'arriver dans ce contexte non vous
savez quand on arrive d'abord quand on a
la chance et l'honneur d'être élu par
les français on n'est pas découragée en
arrivant ça c'est un premier point moi
je suis d'un naturel relativement
optimiste je pense que dans le groupe l
air comme d'ailleurs peut-être dans le
groupe de l'alliance de gauche il ya des
gens de bonne volonté il ya des gens qui
ont le sens de l'intérêt général et des
gens qui se préoccupent du pouvoir
d'achat des français on aura bientôt
l'occasion est bien de mettre sur la
table un projet de loi qui va justement
répondre à ces problématiques là de
manière ambitieuse quoi qu'on en dise à
des gens qui se préoccupent de la
transition écologique des gens qui se
préoccupent de la sécurité donc c'est
gouvernable et je pense que c'est
gouvernable parce que au fond
la situation inédite dans la cavalcade
chaque texte toutefois c'est que c'est
un objectif qui est qui est assez
important mais la situation inédite dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons au fond peut
aussi être vu comme une opportunité
ça fait des années que j'entends parler
en politique ou même d'ailleurs d'être
investi en politique
d'une france qui a du mal avec le
compromis une france qui a du mal avec
le consensus
une france qui a du mal à s'inspirer
d'exemples étrangers je suis d'ailleurs
un député lui en suisse et je me suis
beaucoup intéressée au modèle suisse de
démocratie
lit de la démocratie directe et puis
d'une démocratie parlementaire plus
apaisé je pense qu'on a ici une
opportunité en faisant acte de
conviction en faisant acte de débat et
je suis heureux aussi que le débat
puisse se mener dans des conditions
apaisées et bien d'aller justement
cherché ces députés ses 44 députés dont
on aura besoin pour faire voter les
textes et moi je suis optimiste je pense
qu'on réussira en dépit à les
dépositions de certains chefs de groupe
et nous reste une toute petite minute
avant l'allocution présidentielle très
rapidement qu'est ce que vous attendez
du président ce soir après ce qui s'est
passé dans les urnes
alors connaître une forme de défaite
selon vous oui je pense que là ça crève
les yeux pour le coup donc j'espère
qu'il va la reconnaître j'espère qu'il a
décidé d'écouter pour une fois les
oppositions parce que donc depuis hier
elle a reçu les présidents de groupe il
l'avait fait aussi sous l'ancienne
mandature le problème c'est que rien ne
s'était passé après il avait reçues lui
ai fait un coup de com et derrière rien
du tout dans jeanne le cas sera
différent même question est là
s'adresser aux français oui je pense que
d'abord le président n'a pas à se faire
réélire la fois prochaine il doit
éventuellement il peut prendre la mesure
de ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
produit c'est à dire cette entrée
fracassante parce que justement nous
n'avons pas cette culture du compromis
nous narrant qu'une culture de la digue
et la digue a sauté le rassemblement
national et lou nouveau parti rak
seconde en quelques secondes il doit
montrer qu'il tourne la page de la
verticalité
et il est 20h on va prendre la direction
de l'elysée et voilà vous le voyez pour
suivre en direct la prise de paroles
solennelles du chef de l'état
on va l'écouter
[Musique]
françaises français mes chers
compatriotes le 24 avril vous m'avez
renouveler votre confiance en m'élisant
président de la république vous l'avez
fait sur le fondement d'un projet clair
et en me donnant une légitimité clair
les 12 et 19 juin dernier vous avez voté
pour vos députés élire notre assemblée
nationale
je veux ici félicité les parlementaires
ayant emporté vos suffrages j'ai aussi
une pensée pour les députés sortant
battu
je ne peux d'abord ignoré la forte
abstention qui nous oblige tous à
redonner davantage de sens à nos actions
collectives de lisibilité au grand
rendez vous démocratique
voter est essentielle pour la vie de la
nation pour ces grands choix est très
clairement ce n'est plus ressentie par
tous je ne peux pas davantage ignorer
les fractures les divisions profondes
qui traverse notre pays et se reflète
dans la composition de la nouvelle
assemblée elles expriment des
inquiétudes le sentiment d'avoir des
vies bloqué pas de perspective dans
nombre de nos quartiers populaires comme
dans nos villages
ces élections législatives ont fait de
la majorité présidentielle la première
force politique de l'assemblée nationale
toutefois et c'est un fait nouveau et
comme dans la plupart des démocraties
occidentales qu'il s'agisse de
l'allemagne de l'italie de beaucoup
d'autres aucune force politique ne peut
aujourd'hui faire les lois de seul il a
manqué une trentaine de députés sur 577
et la majorité présidentielle est en
effet relative
sa responsabilité est donc de s'élargir
soit en bâtissant un contrat de
coalition soit en construisant des
majorités texte par texte oui pour agir
dans votre intérêt dans celui de la
nation nous devons collectivement
apprendre à gouverner et légiférer
différemment
bâtir avec les formations politiques
constituant la nouvelle assemblée des
compromis nouveau dans le dialogue
l'écouté le respect c'est ce que vous
avez souhaité et j'en prends acte cela
ne doit pas vouloir dire l'immobilisme
cela doit signifier des accords en
prenant le temps de les faire
par le dialogue le respect l'exigence
j'entends et suis décidé à prendre en
charge la volonté de changement que le
pays a clairement exprimé
parce que c'est mon rôle comme garant de
nos institutions j'ai échangé hier et
aujourd'hui avec les dirigeants de
l'ensemble des formations politiques qui
sont en capacité de constituer un groupe
à l'assemblée nationale
je crois à retranscrire avec justesse la
teneur de nos entretiens en soulignant
d'abord que tous ont fait part de leur
respect pour nos institutions et de leur
volonté d'éviter un blocage pour notre
pays je salue cet esprit de
responsabilité je souhaite qu'il
s'inscrive dans la durée la plupart des
dirigeants que j'ai reçus ont exclu
l'hypothèse d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale
laquelle d'ailleurs n'est à mes yeux pas
justifié à ce jour
beaucoup ont aussi fait part de leur
disponibilité pour avancer sur des
sujets majeurs est urgent pour votre
quotidien le pouvoir d'achat le travail
les moyens d'atteindre le plein emploi
la transition écologique la sécurité je
crois qu'il est donc possible dans le
moment crucial que nous vivons de
trouver une majorité plus large et plus
claire pour agir
vous le savez je suis convaincu de la
nécessité du dépassement politique
depuis le premier jour je les largement
pratiqué et il répond je le sais à
l'aspiration de nombre d'entre vous de
sortir au fond des querelles et des
postures politiciennes de bâtir par le
dialogue le compromis le travail
collectif
je souhaite donc dans les prochaines
semaines que ce dépassement politiques
se poursuivent avec clarté
responsabilités d'abord la clarté ça
veut dire ne jamais perdre la cohérence
du projet que vous avez choisi en avril
dernier c'est un projet d'indépendance
pour notre pays la france est dans notre
europe que nous devons rendre plus
fortes
qui passe par une défense forte et
ambitieuse une recherche d'excellence
une industrie et une agriculture plus
puissante par des investissements
d'avenir un projet de progrès sociaux en
particulier pour notre école et notre
santé qu'il faut refonder sur lesquels
nous devons ré investir un projet de
progrès écologique par une planification
et des investissements assumer un projet
de sécurité et de justice mais aussi un
projet responsable c'est-à-dire crédible
et financé
pour ce faire dès cet été il nous faudra
prendre nous le savons des mesures
d'urgence pour répondre aux besoins du
pays et de votre quotidien une loi pour
le pouvoir d'achat et pour que le
travail paie mieux les premières
décisions pour aller vers le plein
emploi des choix forts sur l'énergie et
le climat des mesures d'urgence pour
notre santé qu'il s'agisse de notre
hôpital ou de l'épidémie tous ces
progrès ne saurait être financé ni par
plus d'impôts n'est par plus de dettes
budgétaires et écologique c'est pourquoi
notre pays plus que jamais a besoin de
réformes ambitieuses pour continuer de
créer plus de richesse plus de travail
et innover davantage
ça c'est la clarté la responsabilité
ensuite il faudra bâtir comme je
l'expliquais des compromis d
enrichissement des amendements mais le
faire en toute transparence à ciel
ouvert si je puis dire dans une volonté
d'union et d'action pour la nation qui
concerne toutes les forces politiques
commencer par la majorité présidentielle
mais toutes les autres mais aussi les
forces vives les partenaires sociaux les
élus les associations nous tous pour
cela il faudra clarifier dans les
prochains jours
la part de responsabilité et de
coopération que les différentes
formations de l'assemblée nationale sont
prêtes à prendre
entrer dans une coalition de
gouvernement et d'action s'engager à
voter simplement certains textes notre
budget lesquels pour avancer utilement
il revient maintenant aux groupes
politiques de dire en toute transparence
jusqu'où ils sont prêts à aller
demain et vendredi je vous représenterez
au conseil européen nous allons examiner
en particulier la question décisive de
la candidature à l'adhésion de l'ukraine
entre on a notre union européenne et du
contexte géopolitique dès mon retour à
la lumière des premiers choix des
premières expressions des groupes
politiques de notre assemblée nationale
nous commencerons à bâtir cette méthode
est cette configuration nouvelle voilà
mes chers compatriotes ce que ce soir je
voulais vous dire j'ai confiance dans
l'esprit de responsabilité de tous j'ai
surtout confiance en vous en nous vous
avez en avril et en juin fait deux choix
clair et j'en prends acte ma
responsabilité c'est de les faire vivre
et de les faire vivre à votre service
pour que la france soit plus forte et
que les réponses soient plus adaptée
construites différemment mais plus
adaptée aux défis de votre quotidien et
du pays je n'aurais qu'une boussole que
nous avancions au service de l'intérêt
général
et j'ai confiance parce qu'ensemble nous
avons traversé tant de crise tant de
difficultés ces dernières années que je
sais que tous ensemble nous trouveront
le chemin de la réussite collective
je vous remercie
vive la république et vive la france
voilà donc pour cette intervention
présidentielle un peu plus de huit
minutes précisément nous allons
apprendre où nous devons apprendre à
légiférer et à gouverner différemment
dans le dialogue l'écouté et le respect
avec deux piliers la responsabilité et
la clarté de chef de l'état qui prend au
jeu ou à témoin les différentes
oppositions en leur demandant très
clairement de mettre presque par écrit
la part de coopération qu'ils sont prêts
à faire les uns et des autres pour
avancer un président voilà je dirais
concentré haas est assez sec dans l'est
dans l'expression et qui ne reconnaît
absolument pas d'échec personnel dans ce
scrutin sur la forme vous qui le
connaissaient bien marc ferracci qu'est
ce que vous pouvez dire je trouve que la
forme était tout à fait clair tout à
fait
transparente puisque le terme a été a
été utilisé moi je retiens cette idée
que j'évoquais d'ailleurs juste avant
son intervention c'est l'idée d'un
certain optimisme on parlait de défaite
tout à l'heure le président a quand même
rappelé il je pense qu'il a eu raison de
le faire que la majorité présidentielle
est et reste la première force politique
du pays je pense qu'il n'est pas
totalement inutile de le rappeler
ensuite je pense que il ya cette
démarche est le terme voit aussi
ici de confiance faire confiance il a
dit aux autres groupes parlementaires
pour dire jusqu'où ils sont prêts à
aller
est-ce que la mare texte on a
l'impression que c'est la démarche qui
est retenu à deux autres chiens maçon ou
alors sur voile avait noté dans
l'ensemble des sujets soit dans le cadre
d'un accord de coalition soit
effectivement texte par texte mais ce
que je retiens également et qui avec
l'expérience que j'ai pu accumuler pour
ma part en travaillant gouvernement
c'est le rapport au temps je pense qu'il
va falloir qu'on prenne plus de temps
pour examiner les textes plus de temps
pour les discuter ça vaudra peut-être
dire d'ailleurs qu'il faudra qu'on vote
moins de texte peut-être en tout état de
cause je pense que la qualité du débat
parlementaire cette nécessité que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure de convaincre
d'aller au fond des arguments de détail
elles ont retardé pour les français les
fameuses efficacité c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai mais je pense que
parfois il faut savoir prendre le temps
pour ensuite aller plus vite plus loin
et surtout pour rendre plus acceptable
les mesures que l'on fait voter par les
français et de ce point de vue je pense
que cette référence autant la
temporalité du processus législatif elle
est importante dans le discours du
président est resté has qu'avez vous
pensé au fond de cette proposition des
nouvelles méthodes fait fait aux
oppositions fait au à la représentation
nationale oui on dirait une nouvelle
méthode il guide nous tous
collectivement différemment bâtir avec
nous parle de dialogue d'écouté de
respect bon mais tout ça c'est très bien
mais ça que c'est surprenant parce qu'on
n'a pas eu l'habitude de le voir agir de
cette façon à l'occasion des cinq
dernières années ça sonne presque un peu
creux dans la bouche des manuels macron
et est ce qui me permet de dire ça c'est
que pour le coup il ne se remet
absolument pas du tout en question et
même pire que ça il essaye de faire il
anticipe en essayant de faire
responsable de faire porter la
responsabilité
de le quasiment l'ingouvernabilité de la
france aux oppositions nous on a une
question claire imposé à monsieur macro
c'est jusqu'où il est prêt à aller
qu'est ce qu'il est prêt à abandonner et
qu'est ce qu'il est prêt à accepter
voulu renvoyé l'argument c'est ça prenez
nos propositions c'est un peu ce que
j'entends votre programme jean philippe
desrosiers l'union nationale n'est pas
justifié à ce jour il n'y a pas prononcé
sauf erreur de ma part le mot de
coalition mais de demander à tous les
partenaires potentiels de dire jusqu'où
ils sont prêts à les textes enfin sujet
par sujet ça que vous avez compris ou
alors l'autre l'autre option ce serait
une méthode de textes par texte
reconstituer on construire des majorités
alors je ne crois pas alors
qu'effectivement prônons dans l'ordre
l'union nationale
considère que ce n'est pas justifié je
pense qu'il a raison les sujets de
d'union nationale sont des sujets d'une
extrême gravité je suis pas en train de
dire quand dans une guerre dans une
situation du pays qui serait
exceptionnel est en pleine croissance
etc nous avons des difficultés qu'il va
falloir résoudre
mais ne sommes pas dans deux guerres ou
d' attaque terroriste d'une grande
ampleur qui a pu justifier même
ponctuellement une union nationale donc
sur ce sujet là je crois que il a il a
raison et je crois que les français
d'ailleurs aurait du mal à trouver les
mots
au maximum
et même fabien roussel a laissé entendre
qu'ils pourraient être ouverts donc on a
le même les deux partis de l'échiquier
mais je crois que globalement ça
manquerait de clarté de trouver un
horizon un sujet qui permettent de faire
converger tous les partis politiques et
les groupes politiques qui sont
représentés dans leur diversité à
l'assemblée nationale maintenant
effectivement il est confronté à une
difficulté inédite sous la vème
république qui est que il dispose non
seulement d'une majorité relative mais
d'une majorité relative assez éloigné de
la majorité absolue pour laquelle il ne
dispose pas d'un allié je dirais
traditionnelle qui pourraient l'appuyer
ou à tout le moins s'abstenir pour
laisser passer les textes parce que la
situation de 1988 on parle assez
régulièrement ces derniers temps où il y
avait déjà eu une majorité relative
d'une part et avant car il manquait une
quinzaine de sièges là et la mangue 45
et il y avait un groupe le parti
communiste qui avait déjà gouverner avec
le parti socialiste et qui avait c'est
qu'un siège donc on pouvait même s'ils
n'ont pas ils ont fait savoir qu'ils ne
voulaient pas soutenir le gouvernement
mais ils ont pu compter quand même
régulièrement sur le l'abstention a
minima la pression qu'à l'issue de cette
allocution on a une piste de solution
concrète ou
qu'il veut faire ce qu'il veut faire
vraisemblablement c'est de construire
des alliances texte par texte comme il
l'a indiqué pas de construire une
alliance durable parce que je pense que
il est suffisamment lucide pour savoir
que ce n'est pas possible d'ailleurs
tous les groupes politiques nous ont
fait savoir que c'était une fin de non
recevoir la
clarification des habilités aux uns et
aux autres pour effectivement soutenir
tantôt la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
tantôt celle sur la revalorisation de
l'assurance chômage la loi de finances
qui devrait être votée annuellement et
la vente
voilà de l'histoire parlementaire de la
pratique de nos institutions c'est voué
à l'immobilisme ou ça peut marcher au
cas par cas alors je pense que ça peut
marcher je pense que ça peut marcher je
soutiens depuis plusieurs jours que le
groupe le pays ingouvernable
il y à une majorité qui n'est pas aussi
forte que celle qu'on aurait pu espérer
est que celles qui étaient détenus avant
avant ce jour 6 mai le gouvernent le
pays ingouvernable au moins dans un
premier temps c'est à dire jusqu'à ce
que des clivages internes à ces
formations réapparaissent que se pose la
question de la succession d'emmanuel
macron puisqu'il ne peut pas être
candidat à sa propre succession dans
dans cinq ans il est limité à deux
mandats que se pose potentiellement la
succession d'autres figures politiques
de premier plan jean luc mélenchon à
gauche peut-être marine le pen à
l'extrême droite et dont tout cela peut
effectivement
conduire vers un an re morcellement et
la rendre plus difficile la gouvernance
à gala vous avez l'impression que ce
soir on est voit plus clair franchement
moi je trouve qu'on y voit déjà un peu
plus fiable parce qu'il ya quelques
jours encore au gouvernement alors on
n'anticipaient pas une telle défaite on
nous disait les majorités au cas par cas
on n'y croit pas les oppositions nous
ferons pas le cadeau de voter avec nous
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche en
france on n'a pas cette culture là là on
voit que c'est l'appel un peu d'
emmanuel macron aux oppositions moi ça
me fait penser on parle d'une célèbre
prise de judo j'ai pas le nom mais on
prend la force de l'adversaire pour le
retourner contre lui là les adversaires
voilà les adversaires des manuels macron
leur force c'est de pouvoir le priver de
la majorité absolue eh ben il retourne
en dix ans maintenant vous allez
expliquer à vos électeurs et aux
français pourquoi par exemple n'allez
pas voter l'arrêt adéquation des
retraites que je vous propose dès cet
été et effectivement c'est il va faire
une liste des choses qui propose il va
dire ben maintenant vous me le dites
clairement pourquoi vous allez voter
contre est-ce que tout simplement c'est
parce que vous êtes dans l'opposition
vous le voter contre voilà donc il va
jouer l'opinion les français contre les
échoués peut-être oui marc ferracci
c'est c'est ça ou quoi en gros et l'idée
c'est quoi dedans dans l'est dans les
dix quinze jours parce que le texte
pouvoir d'achat il arrive en juillet
vous pensez que ça peut fonctionner
c'est cette idée de me prendre à témoin
de mettre au pied du mur les oppositions
pour savoir vraiment au fond ce qu'elles
ont dans le ventre pour les français
parce que ce sont quand même pour que
vous êtes là pour à légiférer sinon quoi
vous il ya la dissolution et je pense
que cette expression de mettre au pied
du mur les et des oppositions et un
petit peu excessive on va effectivement
mettre des textes sur la table pour me
rang desquels celui sur le pouvoir
d'achat on va demander aux oppositions
de se positionner est ce qu'on prend à
témoin l'opinion évidemment les citoyens
seront bien informées à des positions
des uns et des autres mais à un moment
ou un autre on ne peut pas
s'éloigner du projet comporte et encore
une fois le présent été élu sur un
projet ce projet très clairs et ils
abandonner ainsi sont tentés précisément
même si la situation est plus
inconfortable un peu plus j'ai dit c'est
que c'est le mandat de leurs électeurs
de s'opposer et que s'ils ne le font pas
eh bien ils trahissent leurs électeurs
je ne suis pas sûr que le mandat de
certaines oppositions soit de refuser la
réindexation des retraites par exemple
je ne suis pas sûr que le mandat de
certaines oppositions soit de refuser
certains éléments qui figurent dans le
programme et qui à un moment ou un autre
viendront sur la table le fait par
exemple de permettre d'accéder voiture
électrique à bas coûts le fait de mettre
de l'éolien en mer voilà ça peut
intéresser le discours il est déjà là un
moment répondre à un moment je pense je
je termine à un moment on va évidemment
devoir convaincre les oppositions et
plus simplement l'opinion publique comme
ça a été le cas durant la présidentielle
que les mesures que l'on propose sont
bonnes évidemment il y aura un dialogue
y aura comme il était juste dans le
cadre du débat parlementaire en droit
d'amendement mais à un moment ou un
autre je pense qu'il ya des marges de
manoeuvre pour répondre à votre question
c'est pas ça ou rien je pense qu'il faut
donner cette chance il faut donner sa
chance à cette méthode on verra plus
tard si ça ne marche pas étape par étape
soudain un appareil viviane dans un
instant mais vous le savez c'est une
journée riche en actualité à l'assemblée
nationale et on connaît le nom de
du candidat de la coalition
présidentielle pour le perchoir
stéphanie des pierres alors qu'ils qui
est élu pour de kiel vainqueur de cette
primaire interne pour peut-être succédé
à richard ferrand
et bien c'est yale brawn peavey l'actuel
ministre des outre-mer et ancienne
présidente de la commission des lois ici
à l'assemblée qui a été choisi par le
groupe majoritaire pour être candidate
au perchoir alors vous le savez vous
l'avez compris c'est une primaire il
faudra encore que ya le broad pouvait
soit élu par l'ensemble des députés dans
l'hémicycle la semaine prochaine parce
que c'est une élection mais en tout cas
c'est une première étape franchie
pourriez lebron peavey face à elle son
adversaire si l'on peut dire dans cette
primaire c'était roland lescure au
premier tour il était avec 20 points de
différence il ya le groupe iv était
arrivée en tête roland lescure avait
obtenu 67 voyelles brawngp avec 87 voix
les députés de la majorité alors
majorité au sens large il y avait les
députés du groupe renaissance les
députés à d'horizon et les députés du
modem sont réunis depuis à 17h30 et ils
ont discuté longuement il y a fallu deux
tours d'élections pour arriver à ce
résultat et el hadi désignation de yale
brawn québec comme candidate de la
majorité au perchoir ses bons coups
stephany des pierres un tout petit mot
et amanda gava y est lebron peavey
nourrissent et déjà des ambitions avant
d'être nommé ministre d autres mères
puis on savait en ciel en proposant de
la commission des lois voilà on savait
que c'est un poste qui l'intéressent
elle s'en était pas caché c'est vrai
qu'elle a mis en avant et bien sa
gestion de la commission des lois c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu des psychodrames avec
la sphère benalla avec des textes
compliqués mais on sait que l'ambiance
était plutôt bonne qu'elle avait de
bonnes relations avec la droite
notamment et qu' elle était plutôt
apprécié en tant que président de la
commission des lois est l'âme au
perchoir
c'est la première fois absolument si
elle est élue c'est la première faudra
quand même lui rappeler qu'il faut que
le démissionne du gouvernement parce que
pour l'instant n'est pas députés et les
ministres
il faut qu'elles le fassent sans trop
tarder parce que une fois que
l'investiture est passé ça dure un mois
avant qu'elle puisse revenir à
l'assemblée elle est remplacée pendant
un mois pendant son suppléant et ce
n'est qu'au terme d'un délai d'un mois
qu'il peut réintégrer les bons
m le rn a déjà un candidat pour le
perchoir où vous allez attendre décidé
ça demain demande à notre première
grande réunion de groupe demain après
midi donc on décidera ça demain après
midi pas de volonté de blocage parce
qu'il est possible si toutes les
oppositions se finisse bien de ce que
peut être le candidat ne soit pas issu
des rangs de la majorité présidentielle
on verra ça demain vous verrez ça demain
très bien mais on reprend le fil de la
conversation et devises y a d'la c'est
très intéressant ce que ce que disait
tout à l'heure marc ferracci qu'est ce
que vous allez dire aux français qu'ils
sont un peu les arbitres d'une certaine
façon des divisions ou des fractures à
l'assemblée qu'est ce que vous allez
leur dire sur le chèque alimentaire sur
l'indexation des pensions sur sur
l'inflation sur le dégel du point
d'indicé même l'augmentation du poids la
lys comment vous allez faire mais nous c
est très clair on ne travaillera pas les
électeurs qui nous ont élus et donc je
voulais dit tout à l'heure la question
de la réindexation des retraites sur
l'inflation nous voterons pour pourquoi
pas ce que c'était dans notre programme
qu'on va pas voter contre une de nos
propositions par contre ce que vous avez
indiqué tout à l'heure sur les éoliennes
en mer il est évident que nous nous y
opposerons qu'elle soit en mer ou sur
terre dans l'assemblée nationale et
opposés aux éoliennes dont je ne vois
pas quel est le motif positive et faire
le tourneur dacia puisque c'est le
premier grand texte il teste ses j'ose
dire il ya vraiment des mesures sur
lesquelles lesquelles par exemple vous
vous opposez sur ce texte je vais
beaucoup de chaussures de bobigny
tarifaire on connaît l'essentiel il ya
des choses qui vous met d'abord on va
juste prendre quand même le temps de
faire notre travail sérieusement on va
attendre de le recevoir on va le lire on
va le décortiquer on va l'amendé et on
verra au final si pour le coup monsieur
macron et sa majorité bien ou envie de
parler de compromis des coudes de
respect la prudence voilà c'est vraiment
nationale et des nouveaux élus première
réaction ce soir à l'allocution
présidentielle on va écouter jean luc
mélenchon le président ce soir à
réinterpréter le paysage politique en
partant de l'idée qu'il aurait reçu en
avril un mandat clair du pays ce n'est
pas le cas il a été élu en avril
parce qu'une majorité de françaises et
de français ne voulaient pas que
l'extrême droite préside notre
république
depuis les électeurs se sont exprimés
ils ont en majorité
rejeté les propositions des candidats du
président de la république
l'exécutif est faible mais l'assemblée
nationale est forte de toute la
légitimité de son élection toute récente
la première ministre doit se présenter
devant l'assemblée nationale
présenté un programme d'actions et
solliciter la confiance de l'assemblée
si elle ne l'a pas cette confiance elle
doit démissionner si elle l'a elle devra
ensuite faire des propositions de textes
de loi et l'assemblée en discutera comme
elle a discuté de tous les autres textes
de loi dans le passé marc féral si le
vote de confiance de la première
ministre si c'est toujours elisabeth
bornes ce sera sans doute le 4 juillet
un discours de politique générale qui
est qui est prévu est il nécessaire
doit-elle engager sa responsabilité
c'est ce que réclame jean luc mélenchon
c'est assez légitime pour une première
ministre qui commence à un quart entre
en fonction sur dans une situation comme
ça est ce que vous pensez que les
français comprendraient qu'elle ne
prenne pas au fond le risque de la
confiance vu le rôle d'un discours de
politique générale c'est précisément de
tracer la feuille de route qui va être
celle du gouvernement en application du
projet du président de la république la
feuille de route sur le fond est la
feuille de route en méthode je pense que
il est très classique que les
oppositions à cette occasion manifeste
et bien leurs critiques le fond le
ferons à travers les discours des
présidents de groupe mais il me semble
absolument pas un gros risque est
nécessaire aujourd'hui ni nécessaire ni
justifié que la première est que la
première ministre met en jeu sa
responsabilité
qu'est ce que vous répondez à jean luc
mélenchon ce soir qu' on voit bien ne
veut pas voilà
avoir la moindre oreille attentive à ce
qu'a dit le président de la république
il renvoie très clairement à un vote de
confiance qui était périlleux pour vous
jean luc mélenchon n'est plus député
autant que je le sache il s'exprime en
tant que chef de parti que chef d'un
parti qui a longtemps qui s'est
longtemps prévalu d'être d'ailleurs dans
l'horizontalité de ne pas véritablement
avoir de chef donc ça ne l'a évidemment
jamais trompé personne donc on écoute
courtoisement jean luc mélenchon on
n'est pas obligé de suivre ses avis jean
philippe derosier peut-être qu'il faut
expliquer les enjeux en terme de vote si
la première ministre engage sa
responsabilité
alors seuls les votants seront
comptabilisés ce qui fait baisser
considérablement
le seuil de la majorité à atteindre est
là
compte tenu de la nouvelle assemblée
elle peut tomber oui absolument c'est
l'article 49 alinéa 1er de la
constitution qui permet au premier
ministre la première ministre d'engager
sa responsabilité d'engager la
responsabilité du gouvernement
collectivement sur une déclaration de
politique générale et on vote et c'est
la majorité simple qui détermine si la
confiance est accordée ou si la
confiance est refusée si la confiance
est refusé c'est à dire que il ya une
majorité refusant la confiance qui
l'emportent alors constitutionnellement
le gouvernement la première ministre est
contrainte de démissionner c'est le jeu
rythmé ans on le sait très bien c'est
plus facile avec cette méthode de la
confiance la motion de censure ou là il
faut obtenir une majorité de 289 x
contre le gouvernement soutenant la
motion de censure mais à dire l'ensemble
déposer des oppositions l'est
républicain le rassemblement
luc mélenchon dit elle doit venir non
effectivement la constitution de l'impôt
ce pas une simple faculté et madame
borne peut également faire une
déclaration qu'elle peut appeler de
politique générale sur le fondement d'un
autre article de la constitution que
l'arctique 50-1 qui lui permet de faire
une telle déclaration sans qu' il y ait
un engagement de la responsabilité
il pourrait même y avoir un vote et ce
vote n'auraient pas de conséquence sur
la survie du gouvernement et vite si
elle engage à sa responsabilité alors
que voilà tout commence un et vous votez
ça serait très risqué qu'est-ce que vous
votez votez la confiance ou pas je pense
pas qu'on voterait la confiance à
l'égard de madame bornes qui a été nommé
précisément pour appliquer la politique
d' emmanuel macron que nous avons
combattu mais savait que ça serait très
très risqué que pour elle surtout quand
on voit le résultat des élections
législatives où un certain nombre de
ministres et des ministres connus ont
été battus parfois dès le premier tour
après je trouve que monsieur mélenchon
et pour le coup assez habile dans en
évoquant cette méthode mais pour le coup
sûr mélenchon ça ne trompe plus personne
il a essuyé de nombreux échecs il n'a
pas réussi à se qualifier au second tour
de la présidentielle
il n'est pas premier ministre qu'on vend
à ce qui nous avait vendu et puis
aujourd'hui et puis député donc en fait
il n'est même pas prêts à leur groupe
donc il essaye d'exister comme il peut
mais on voit quand même que c'est
difficile pour lui alors pour porter au
fond ce qu'on pourrait appeler une forme
de tentatives pas comment on peut
appeler ça des négociations texte par
texte il n'y a pas de mot signé une
coalition dont celui en plaques de
gouvernement c'est potentiellement une
géométrie une qu'une majorité à
géométrie variable ou aurait
avec les uns avec les autres car il
n'est pas indispensable d'avoir 289 voix
c'est à dire la majorité absolue sur
chaque texte à la majorité relative
suffit et donc l'abstention d'un groupe
suffisamment important que ce soit le
rassemblement national où les
républicains ou boire la france
insoumise suffirait alors dernière
question très rapidement parce que ce
débat s'achève elisabeth bornes avec ou
sans elisabeth borne est ce que déjà
françois bayrou 10 m 1 très clairement
qu'il faut un profil politique très
clairement il indique que ça n'est pas
pour lui la bonne la bonne option il
organisa en bouleau cissé qu'elisabeth
bornes c'est une femme ça n'aura échappé
à personne et que d'émettre une femme
quelques semaines après l'avoir nommé
c'est à moins de nos les nouvelles rames
très très compliqué ce serait que les
deux gouverneurs et des cours de
l'histoire de la république ce serait
des gouvernements exactement pour
conclure d'un mot marquer ratées vous
souhaitez qu'elle reste en fonction à
matignon je souhaite que resto
fonctionne matignon merci merci pour la
concision merci d'avoir accepté de venir
réagir à chaud à cette allocution
présidentielle rester avec nous sur lcp
votre soirée documentaire commence
maintenant avec jean pierre gratien on
va continuer à en parler de ce chaos
institutionnel a les mots n'est pas trop
fort à demain
[Musique]